for those who are sick of hearing about
Donald Trump's campaign for 2024's
Republican nomination today may be a
welcome change for you we are going to
take a deeper dive into the last 48
hours of the Ron DeSantis candidacy for
the 2024 Republican Presidential
nomination now one of the things that
will not please those who are sick of
hearing about Trump is that DeSantis is
widely emulating Trump so far in the
early days of his campaign in a number
of different ways including even some of
the insults that Trump uh became famous
for so Ron DeSantis spoke in Iowa
yesterday and there are a number of
different disturbing and comical
realities first and foremost we talked
yesterday about how Ron DeSantis said he
would very much consider pardoning
Donald Trump if he were to become
president if you're running against
Trump you're not going to win by saying
I'll pardon him because the people who
want Trump will vote for Trump and the
people who were disgusted by Trump
aren't going to want to go with the guy
that says I will pardon Trump who you
want to get away from you're not going
to beat Trump by avoiding conflict and
criticism the way that DeSantis has done
to a degree in the pre-campaign stages
of the last few months and you're
certainly not going to defeat Trump
by using the same insults that some
people like in which case they'd vote
for Trump and some people don't like in
which case they're not going to vote for
the guy copying the insults and Ron
DeSantis yesterday during this speech in
Iowa going with the Biden is in the
basement thing which is a trump thing
this was Trump's line throughout the
2020 campaign our
can come back
by sending Joe Biden back to his
basement in Delaware
you're not going to win this way Ron I
mean this is if if there's a couple
different issues here first he needs to
defeat Trump before he gets a shot at
Joe Biden and so I you all know I don't
get into this whole Alpha Beta way of
discussing everything by the standards
of these right Wingers it's not very
Alpha to go after the guy you're not
even running against in order to avoid
conflict with the guy who's actually up
30 points in the polls now we're going
to talk about polling a little bit later
because since his announcement DeSantis
is actually up 15 in the polling now
let's remember 15 and 15 percentage
points are two different things before I
get emails saying David what are you
talking about
DeSantis is up 15 in the polls we'll
talk about that later but this seems to
be a bump and not a shift in the
underlying dynamics of this campaign
which are that the majority of the
Republican party is fine with Trump and
those that aren't aren't looking for a
guy with the same insults and the same
hand movements who's unwilling to
actually take Trump on head-on and
instead is going to go after Joe Biden
all right let's look at some more clips
from this uh Speech here is DeSantis
talking about the debt deal and you know
one of the really interesting things
about American politics where there's a
history of state level officials vying
for national office Bill Clinton was the
governor of Arkansas and then ran for
president what Bill Clinton had that
DeSantis very much does not have is that
even though Bill Clinton was this sort
of
Southern State Governor
when his campaign for president launched
and he was talking about foreign policy
and debt and deficit Etc he didn't seem
completely in uh over in over his head
you're going to hear Ron DeSantis talk
about debt and you will see that this
state elected official seems completely
out of his element and completely in
over his head when discussing the topics
that are relevant to the National
political scene
[Applause]
we now see Washington has now cooked up
their latest quote debt deal and I can
tell you this our nation was careening
towards bankruptcy before the debt deal
and it will still be careening towards
bankruptcy after this debt deal this is
green lighting four trillion dollars in
new debt in less than two years it took
us almost 200 years to get to 4 trillion
in debt in the first place now remember
when we're talking about the debt
ceiling and the debt limit and all of
this stuff aside from the fact that most
of these elected officials don't even
have the most basic understanding of
macroeconomics like put that aside for a
second the debt limit relates to paying
obligations that have already been
authorized it is not actually about new
spending when these Republicans show up
and say we're to new spending new
spending new spending all of this
spending has already been agreed upon
and it has been agreed upon by our
elected officials in the House and
Senate you might say well I'm a
Republican and when this stuff was
agreed upon we didn't have the house or
Senator okay but this is the process we
have and this is all spending that has
already been authorized now we're
talking about meeting our existing
obligations it locks in inflated covid
level uh uh era levels of spending and
it keeps 98 of the 87 000 new IRS agents
that Joe Biden instituted
is not going to solve our nation's
fiscal problems so again now we are just
quite literally the to Trump lines these
are now I know you're trying to appeal
to Republicans and some of the stuff
Trump does appeals to Republicans and so
you're gonna have to do some of the same
stuff but at some point how are you
going to that this is Trump's lines
delivered in a really just off-putting
way right I mean we're just it's gonna
be dad and it was bankruptcy and I'll
tell so it's the Trump lines delivered
in a winier voice in Florida we run
budget surpluses we have a 1.2 trillion
dollar GDP in Florida we'd be the 13th
largest economy in the world if we were
our separate country and yet with 1.2
trillion economy our state debt is only
17 billion dollars all right so the
crowd not super engaged as you can see
and DeSantis offering nothing that we
might qualify as inspire firing then he
went completely off the rails in
delusions of grandeur saying he believes
we can bring George Washington back and
this is when I mean listen there is some
narcissism probably required to even
think hey I should run for president
maybe people will vote for me but this
is really too much bureaucracy is so
entrenched that I think we can bring
George Washington back can you and I
don't think he could fix it in one
single four-year term but DeSantis can
do it in two terms that's the great news
our nation we
every major institution in our country
going on ideological Joyrides we have to
be guided by Reality by facts and by our
enduring principles we in the State of
Florida held the line when Freedom hung
in the balance
yeah so there is nothing I am seeing
here that makes me think this is
Electric in a way that it's going to put
Trump out with Republican voters the
biggest argument that DeSantis is making
is Florida good I make America like
Florida I am going to argue next that
that would be a disaster if you deal
with anxiety or depression you may have
tried meditation exercise diet changes
therapy all of which are important
things to try there is also a new
treatment that we've been talking about
on the program for years which for many
people has been a game changer and that
is ketamine therapy the research around
ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improvements in their anxiety
and depression after just two sessions
read about the evidence for ketamine
therapy we've talked about it on the
show it's pretty remarkable stuff mind
Bloom is offering my audience a hundred
dollars off your first six session
program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description